kokalla maïga
premiers ministres des chefs de
gouvernement de la république du mali et
je l'invite à prendre la parole devant
l'assemblée
c'est le président de l'assemblée
générale
mesdames et messieurs les chefs d'état
et de gouvernement
mais c'est le secrétaire général de
l'organisation des nations unies
mesdames et messieurs
je voudrais avant tout propos vous
adresser les salutations fraternelles du
peuple africain du mali et celle du
président de la transition
chef de l'état son excellence le colonel
à 6008 a
ajouté également à leurs dons et à mon
nom propre vous d'adressé monsieur le
président les chaleureuses félicitations
de la délégation du mali où votre
brillante élection à la présidence de
cette 66ème session de l'assemblée
générale
je félicite également votre prédécesseur
son excellence monsieur volcan buzz
qu'il la république de turquie pour la
manière remarquable avec laquelle il a
dirigé les travaux de la 64ème session
de l'assemblée générale
qu'il me soit permis également de
réitérer à notre secrétaire général
monsieur antonio guterres notre
appréciation des efforts louables qu'il
continue de déployer ou la réalisation
des nobles objectifs de notre
organisation commune sur le président à
la 65ème session ordinaire de
l'assemblée générale souvent fort
opportunément sur le thème de l'espoir
l'espoir de renforcer notre résilience
pour nous relever de la pandémie de la
cour buts 19 dans un esprit de
responsabilité de coopération de
solidarité
l'espoir dément le plus sûr des membres
de sécurité humaine l'espoir que les
sels retrouve la stabilité ne devienne
un havre de paix et un pôle de
croissance et du développement
l'espoir en fait de revitaliser
l'organisation des nations unies le
manuscrit pleinement à l'esprit et à la
lettre de ce thème qui résume
parfaitement les idéaux de notre
organisation commune c'est une
lapalissade d'affirmer que le mali et
les pays du sahel sont de nos jours
confronté à l'hydre terroriste à
l'extrémisme violent et à l'instabilité
c'est la dure depuis le début d'une
décennie avec le risque d' alice mme de
banalisation ou de lassitude propre à
détourner cette problématique de
l'agenda international
à notre quotidien fait d'angoise et des
tragédies est venue s'ajouter la
pandémie de la cour 8,19 avec ses effets
négatifs sur l'économie et sur les
conditions de vie de nos populations
déjà précaire du fait des défis
économiques politiques et humanitaires
rarement un pays ou une région a été
aussi durement éprouvée à la liz may
l'empilement des crises plus que le mali
et les états du sahel c'est dans ce
contexte difficile que le peuple malien
après plusieurs mois de soulèvement
populaire a choisi l'autre direction un
autre pays est placé tous ses espoirs
dans le processus de transition
politique en cours dont il est l'artisan
principal le gouvernement de transition
que j'ai l'honneur de diriger des pulls
en juin 2021 comprend les représentants
des forces vives du mali fait notable il
comprend aussi dans un souci
d'inclusivité des membres des mouvements
signataires de l'accord pour la paix et
la réconciliation issue du processus
d'alger ainsi que des représentants des
forces politiques et sociales de notre
pays
aussitôt installé nous avons travaillé
ensemble à l'élaboration du plan
d'action du gouvernement de transition
qui contient un ensemble de mesures dans
la mise en oeuvre a assuré
la prise en charge des préoccupations
majeures des populations éprouvées par
la crise sécuritaire politique sanitaire
et économique ce plan d'action du
gouvernement
adopté le 2 août 2021 par le conseil
national de transition organe législatif
transitoire
s'articule autour de quatre axes
prioritaires il est assorti d'un
chronogramme d'exécution et d'un budget
prévisionnel le premier axe du plan
d'action du gouvernement elise la
sécurité au rang de priorité élevé il
répond à l'aspiration profonde de notre
peuple à la paix la quiétude où vivre
ensemble à la cohabitation pacifique à
la cohésion sociale en effet malgré le
succès indéniable a révisé par les
forces armées maliennes et leurs alliés
auxquels je rends hommage
les menaces entrantes unis pas le
terrorisme et les autres formes de
banditisme de criminalité transnationale
continuent hélas attendait notre peuple
au quotidien et à menacer les fondements
de l'état de mars 2012 à ce 25 septembre
2021 où je m'adresse à vous du bourg de
cet auguste tribune la citation dans mon
pays laissait guère améliorée malgré le
soutien international et la présence sur
notre sol d'une opération de paix de
l'onu la munition et des forces
internationales telles que l' opération
française barkan la force européenne
qu'à cuba et la force conjointe du jeu
sincère
la situation continue progressivement de
se détourner au point que des pans
entiers du territoire national échappent
au contrôle du gouvernement mais ce qu
elles vivent sous l'emprise de groupes
armés terrorisent dans le déni de leurs
droits les plus élémentaires
leur accès aux services de base des
maris politique en raison de la faible
présence des services de l'état
consécutive à l'insécurité grandissante
la ministre devait saluer ici le courage
et la contribution à la stabilisation du
mali évolué dans cet environnement ville
avec ce que cela comporte comme menace
sur elle face à cette situation
préoccupante
le gouvernement est régulièrement et
fortement interpellée par les
populations maliennes de plus en plus
exigeante vis-à-vis des pouvoirs publics
et des partenaires internationaux
s'il est établi que l'un des droits
fondamentaux des populations et le droit
à la sécurité la garantie de celle ci
assurément l élément de légitimation de
l'état aux yeux des sites web c'est le
président je fais ce rappel pour vous
restituer l'exacte situation du calvaire
qu'endurent les populations maliennes je
les fais aussi pour nous convier tous
ensemble à l'introspection afin de
charger de paradigme en matière de
sécurité au sahel le mali qu'on vous le
savez accueille sur son territoire une
opération de paix des nations unies et
je voudrais à nouveau rendre hommage
hommage appuyé à toutes ces femmes et à
tous ces hommes qui travaillent sous la
bannière de la minustah dans des
conditions difficiles souvent
périlleuses pour préserver la paix et
pour protéger les populations civiles
je rappelle que notre organisation
commune l'onu a été bien avisé en 2013
lorsqu'elle a décidé de déployer fort
opportunément la mission multi
dimensionnelle intégré des nations unies
pour la stabilisation du mali mini
semant la résolution 21 00 du 25 avril
2016 établissant la ministre avait
considéré le site que la situation au
mali constitue une menace pour la paix
et la sécurité internationales et a
décidé en conséquence
d'agir en vertu du chapitre 7 de la
charte des nations unies
dans son paragraphe 16 la résolution 21
00 a fixé comme mandat initial à la
minus mans entre outre je cite d'appuyer
les autorités de transition malienne
pour stabiliser la situation dans les
principales agglomérations en
particulier dans le nord épi est dans ce
contexte écarter les menaces et prennent
activement des dispositions afin
d'empêcher lé retour d'éléments armés
dans ces zones la résolution 21 64 du 25
juin 2014 qui a renouvelé pour la
première fois le mandat de la minus mans
pourrait n'en a souligné je cite que le
terrorisme ne peut être vaincue à la
faveur d'une démarche suivie et globales
fondées la participation et la
collaboration active de l'ensemble des
états et organismes régionaux et
internationaux visant à contrer
affaiblir et isoler la menace terroriste
fin de citation en conséquence le
paragraphe 12 de ladite résolution
autorisait la minus mans je cite à
utiliser tous les moyens nécessaires
pour accomplir son mandat dans les
limites de ses capacités et dans ces
zones de déploiement et lui un joueur en
particulier au titre du paragraphe thèse
je cite d'étendre sa présence notamment
grâce à des patrouilles de longue portée
dans les limites de ses capacités dans
le nord du pays au délà des principales
agglomérations et en particulier dans
les zones où les civils sont en danger
seul président à 8 ha après le
déploiement de l'amusement les extraits
ci dessus
la résolution d'intérêt 00 de 2013 il
est la résolution
21,64 de 2014 sont d'une évidente les
brûlante actualité
les populations maliens sont exacerbées
aujourd'hui devant les tueries de masse
des villages rasés de la carte et
d'innocents civils fauchés dans les
femmes et les nourrissant souvent brûlés
vifs les maliennes et maliens ont le net
sentiment que la mission assignée à la
minus mans a changé en cours de route et
notamment des pluies 2015 suite à la
signature de l'accord pour la paix la
réconciliation
issue du procès d'ali alors même que les
défis qu'on justifie son diplôme à sont
laissés constants
en effet contrairement aux attentes du
peuple malien l'environnement notamment
terroristes dans laquelle la ministre a
été déployé en 2013 s'est dégradée
continuellement au fil du temps il s'est
même métastasique car les groupes armés
terroristes qui ont en pris près de deux
tiers de notre territoire en 2012 ont
été dispersés sans jamais être anéantie
ils se sont reconstitués et se sont
renforcés c'est dans ce contexte de
menace préoccupant que l'armée française
à travers l'opération serval d'abord et
ensuite l'opération marcal a été
autorisée à mener un soutien à la
munition et anoeta le volet lutte contre
le terrorisme au mali c'est également
dans ce conte est ce le président a que
l'opération française barca alors
subitement sort était en vue du temps
une transformation coalition
internationale dont tous les contours ne
sont pas encore connus en tout cas pas
de mon pays pas du monde de notre peuple
la noce unilatérale du retrait de barkan
et sa transformation non pas une école
du lien tripartite qui nous lie c'est à
dire l'onu le mali en tant que
partenaire engagé avec la france sur le
front de la lutte contre les facteurs
d'une déstabilisation le mali regrettes
que le principe de consultation et de
concertation qui doit être la règle
entre partenaires privilégiés n'est pas
été observé en amont de la décision du
gouvernement français aussi la nouvelle
situation née de la fin de barkan la
salle le mali devant le fait accompli et
les skoda il a une espèce d'abandon en
plein vol nous conduit à explorer les
voies et moyens pour mieux assurer la
sécurité de manière autonome avec
d'autres partenaires de manière à
combler le vide qui ne manquera pas de
créer la fermeture de sept 7 ans en plus
de barkan dans le nord du mali cette
situation doit également incité les
nations avoir désormais une pause
surprise offensive sur le terrain le
président a il n'existe pas de
sentiments intimes unis semant au mali
pas plus qu'il n'existe de sentiments
anti français dans notre pays non je le
dis sans ambages
notre peuple n'a jamais été un peuple
ingrat au sommet de l'état et au sein
des populations il existe un désir de
paix une soif de sécurité qu'il faut éco
à l'exigence d'efficacité des
instruments et des mécanismes politiques
et militaires mis en place et qui font
paradoxalement du mali est un pays sûr
militarisé mais très vulnérable face au
terrorisme devenu un facteur de
désintégration de l'état de nos sociétés
et de déstabilisation des fondements de
nos pays que devrions nous faire face à
un tel paradoxe que faut-il faire pour
répondre à l' angoisse à l'exaspération
et la colère des populations maliennes
que faut-il faire pour répondre au
sentiment d'insatisfaction à la fois des
maliens et des partenaires du mali du
pass humblement seul président que face
à ces interrogations nous devons avoir
le courage et la lucidité
d'interroger les instruments et les
mécanismes et évoqué plus haut nous
désirons aussi et surtout remettre sur
la table le mot la démarche d'un mandat
plus robuste et d'un changement de poste
de la milice maï règlement fait
régulièrement faites par le gouvernement
au conseil de sécurité de l'onu ceci
permettra d'adapter le mana de la mini
cement de lui donner les moyens de
s'acquitter convenablement de son mandat
et de répondre à l'aspiration du peuple
malien aspire à sens à laquelle ni la
mission de l'onu ni les autres
partenaires militaires internationaux
présents sur notre sol
noront la crédibilité aux yeux de me
constituer en termes clairs les nations
unies doivent aider le mali a lutté
efficacement
contre la criminalité transfrontalière
organisée afin d'asseoir les conditions
véritables sa stabilisation gage de la
réussite des actions de soutien
politique humanitaire de développement
et de progression des droits de l'homme
s'il est établi que la situation au mali
constitue une menace pour la paix et la
sécurité internationales ils nous
reviennent donc dû trouver les voies et
moyens idoines pour continuer à y faire
face de manière holistique
solidaires et déterminés registre à
l'éradication de la dite menace le
président dans la guerre sans merci que
mène contre lutte qu'ils mènent contre
le terrorisme le gouvernement du mali ne
ménagera aucun effort pour remplir ses
obligations internationales
envers le respect des droits de l'homme
il accorde la plus haute importance à la
coordination
des actions de nos partenaires sur le
terrain la coopération régionale pour
tenir compte de la dimension régionale
de la crise sécuritaire au sel c'est
tout le sens de notre engagement de la
force conjointe des cinq sets c'est
aussi tous les salles de notre demande
commune au sein du gsm celles en faveur
d'un mandat robuste et adapté sous le
chapitre 7 de la charte des nations
unies et d'un financement prévisible et
perrin la force qu'on vienne du fn celle
d'alain souci de cohérence et
d'efficacité
le gouvernement s'attelle à la mise en
place sous mon autorité d'une structure
de suivi de coordination des activités
de la mini semant ainsi qu'à
l'élaboration d'une stratégie de gestion
intégrée de la crise au centre du mali
nous nous donnerons pas de la
responsabilité propre dans le processus
de stabilisation du mali le gouvernement
de transition a une claire conscience
que cette stabilisation passe aussi à la
mise en oeuvre de l'accord pour la paix
la réconciliation issue du processus
d'alliés au demeurant le gouvernement et
les mouvements signataires ainsi que
c'est de l'inclusivité poursuivre la
mise en oeuvre de l'accord dans un
esprit de confiance
et de responsabilité au sein d'un cas de
nouveau appelé cadres intermédiaires
pour la mise en oeuvre de l'accord dans
cet esprit nous poursuivons la mise en
oeuvre intelligente et l'arrêt lecture
conte essentielle de l'accord aux fins
de son parachèvement
l'objectif recherché étant de favoriser
son appropriation nationale et de
renforcer son caractère inclusif tout en
veillant aux conditions politiques et
sociales du consensus nécessaire à la
lecture de certaines dispositions
conformément aux mécanismes prévus par
l'accord concernant les questions de
défense et de sécurité un programme de
désarmement démobilisation et de
réinsertion portant sur trois mille ex
combattants issus de mouvements
signataires et de l'inclusivité été mis
en place sur lesquels
1840 s combattants ont déjà été
intégrées le gouvernement a également
exprimé sa volonté d'intégrer 2160
restant au plus tard le 21 août 2021
n'eût été la lenteur accusée par la
coordination des mouvements de l'azawad
dans la fourniture de la liste de celles
présentes par ailleurs le gouvernement
du mali est disposé à l'intégration
prochaine des ex combattants au sein des
forces des sécurité de la fonction
publique de l'état et d'autres corps
paramilitaire dès que les quotas
compatible avec les capacités du budget
national sont fixés le gouvernement est
déterminé à surmonter les obstacles
techniques qui mène qui émane des autres
parties à l'accord en particulier des
mouvements signataires dont l'adhésion
au des ders doit peut-être sans réserve
le volet réinsertion socio-économique
entamera les activités d'ici la fin du
mois de septembre avec l'appui de la
munition et de la banque mondiale je
n'oublie pas ici la situation des
réfugiés maliens dans les pays voisins
et des personnes déplacées internes qui
reste une préoccupation majeure du
gouvernement nous attèlerons à créer
avec l'appui des partenaires bilatéraux
et multilatéraux les conditions idoines
d'un retour de la sécurité et de la
dignité de nos populations et à assurer
leur participation aux prochaines
élections c'est le président à la
transition en cours au mali cv une
transition de rupture qui porte l'espoir
de guérir le mali des mots qu'il la cei
dans l'instabilité politique et
institutionnelle l'affaissement de
l'état conséquence directe de la
corruption et de l'impunité pour réussir
ce pari notre pays a décidé de s'engager
dans la voie des réformes qui constitue
le deuxième axe du plan d'action du
gouvernement ces réformes vont au delà
des questions politiques et
institutionnelles et vise in fine et à
réformer l'état dans les délitement
progressif à la bad de lectra
vulnérabilité du mali face aux défis
politiques économiques et sociaux
auxquels il est confronté
mon pays souhaitent être une solution
aux crises qui menacent le sel de mal et
aspire vivre en paix avec ses ouailles à
renforcer son unité sa stabilité et de
recouvrer la plénitude de sa
souveraineté sur tout son territoire le
mali veut garantir la sécurité humaine à
l'intérieur de ses frontières en
consolidant ses institutions
constitutionnelles
à cette fin le mali engagé à faire sa
mue à travers les réformes a amorcé sa
transformation vers un état stable et
prospère
orienté vers le bien-être de ses
habitants
ces réformes ont trop longtemps été
différée pad pour différentes raisons
par les différents régimes politiques
qui sont succédé au pouvoir depuis deux
décennies la transition en cours sous la
haute conduite de son excellence de koné
lassiné huit ans a décidé de s'y engager
fermement
les chef de l'état nous a commis a
convoqué l'état les tout prochains jours
les assises nationales de la réfondation
dans les recommandations renforce
exécutoire aussi bien pour la période de
transition en cours que pour la
poursuite des politiques publiques à
venir
le troisième axe prioritaire du
gouvernement est consacré à
l'organisation des élections générales
transparentes crédibles et inclusive
devant marquer le retour à l'ordre
constitutionnel au mali ces élections
régulières non pas qu'il est important
qu'elles elles seront le baromètre de la
réussite de la transition
nous savons que leur qualité leur
crédibilité conditionnant l'avenir de
notre démocratie la légitimité et la
solidité des institutions
qui râlent et les sens de notre pratique
démocratique récente du gouvernement va
instituer un organe unique indépendant
de gestion des élections cet organe
unique de gestion des élections posera
les jalons politique juridique
institutionnel de la restauration de la
confiance des acteurs politiques et des
citoyens lors des compétitions
électorales il s'agit là d'une
innovation majeure dé nature à renforcer
la démocratie et la légitimité des
institutions
nous avons conscience des délais
impartis à la transition et de nos
engagements internationaux nous
travaillons sans relâche à les respecter
dans cette optique l'organe de gestion
suivra un processus accéléré de mise en
oeuvre à travers l'art et l'étude de la
loi électorale l'installation d'un
directoire national et des démembrements
au niveau régional et local et dans les
ambassades et consulats du mali à cet
égard la table ronde sur l'examen de
l'avant-projet des temps de référence
des assises nationales de la réfondation
est ouvert aujourd'hui hier à bamako au
delà de l'acquisition de l'organe munich
de gestion des élections le gouvernement
va s'atteler à réformer le système
électoral à travers l'art et l'étude des
textes fondamentaux riz du ca les
élections enfin sur le président de 4 à
max de la l'action gouvernementale
consistera à instaurer la bonne
gouvernance et l'adoption d'un pacte de
stabilité ceux-ci chapitre du
gouvernement s'est engagé à assurer une
gouvernance de rupture et d'exemplarité
une lutte implacable et déjà
engagés pour combattre la corruption et
l'impunité qui sont à la base de la
déliquescence de l'état les mesures en
cours dans ce sens vont se poursuivre et
s'intensifier
la gouvernance de risque il s'établit
d'ores et déjà par une rue du centre à
ce déclin de vue de l'état afin de
dégager des espaces budgétaires pour
améliorer les conditions de vie des
populations et assurer une répartition
équitable des richesses nationales
le président de la transition et le
gouvernement ont déjà donné de bons
exemples dans ce sens les ressources
ainsi dégagées seraient affectés vers
les services sociaux de base pour plus
de justice et d'équité entre les
travailleurs le gouvernement après avoir
procédé à l'harmonisation l'église
salariale au sein de la fonction
publique va initier dans les meilleurs
délais une conférence sociale en
concertation avec les partenaires
sociaux et les acteurs du monde du
travail sur le président pays sahélien à
vocation essentiellement agricole
d'élevage et de pêche du mali demeure
fortement préoccupés par les changements
climatiques qui constitue l'un des défis
majeurs pour la survie et les deux
dauphins de l'humanité en effet mon pays
subit de plein fouet les effets du
changement climatique caractérisé par
l'avancé et la désertification et son
impact sur la faune et la flore lâché
sma de nos fleuves et de nos cours d'eau
l'augmentation du niveau des salaires
les inondations et cetera et cetera
c'est pourquoi je voudrais réaffirmer
l'attachement du mali à la mise en
oeuvre de l'accord de paris sur le
climat c'est le président du rdda
conclure en rappelant que l'action du
gouvernement de transition au mali et
orienter ses trois piliers qui
correspond à trois besoins vitaux pour
l'humanite il s'agit du besoin de
sécurité du baiser de justice pour
lutter contre la corruption et
l'impunité et du besoin de la femme
j'allais dire de la fondation il est
impérieux de continuer à travailler à
améliorer l'environnement de sécurité au
mali avec l'aide des amis du mali en
appui aux efforts des forces de défense
et de sécurité il est tout aussi
impérieux de mener les réformes
nécessaires à la refondation de l'est et
à l'adaptation des textes régissant les
élections aux besoins de la société
malienne et aux évolutions du tas il n'y
a pas d'alternative aux réformes qu'il
nécessite l'état désastreux du mali
si nous voulons faire en sorte que ce
grand pays reste debout et devient
stable la cedeao à bien appréhender cela
et dès octobre 2018 elle avait
recommandé à l'issue de sa mission
d'information relative à la crise
postélectorale de mener les réformes à
cette heure du site prenant acte de la
prolongation de la législature actuelle
selon l'avis de la cour
constitutionnelle et au regard des
dysfonctionnements largement reconnu est
évoquée par tous les interlocuteurs lors
du scrutin présidentiel passé il est
impératif que le gouvernement et tous
les acteurs sociaux politiques
conviennent d'une manière prince en ciel
d'entreprendre des réformes courageuses
des cadres légaux y compris la
constitution de février 1992 et du
système électoral avant de s'engager
dans les prochaines élections que compte
mener le pays je dois dire que cette
importante et recommandations des cdo
n'a pas été suivie d'effet à ce jour le
gouvernement de transition qui est
l'honneur de diriger s'attelle à la mise
en oeuvre diligente de cette mesure je
saisis cette occasion pour renouveler la
gratuite du président de la transition
du gouvernement et du peuple malien aux
chefs d'état et de gouvernement de la
cedeao pour le leadership et pour leur
présence constante aux côtés du mali en
ces moments difficiles complexes les
exhortant à continuer à avoir une
lecture lucide de la situation qui
prévaut au mali un pays vaste ouvert sur
cette frontière et qui constitue une
digue pour toute la région ou à
l'africaine vous remercie de votre
aimable attention
au nom de l'assemblée générale je tiens
à remercier le premier ministre et chef
de gouvernement de la république du mali
de l'allocution qu'il vient de prononcer
j'ai prié le protocole de bien vouloir
accompagner son excellence